you're at a point now where I think
Bitcoin is gathering because people are
losing trust in the US this year in 2023
70 of global growth will occur in Asia
and China in particular's M2 has grown
by five trillion dollars since October
so when China's money supply is
increasing which was not happening last
year Bitcoin typically does well and
right now all of those things are
pointed the same direction you have the
AI Innovation side you have the FED
under attack along with the dollar
because of the banking sector and the
debt ceiling and you have Asia
dominating the growth because the
China's reopening and the printing of
money all right guys bang bang I've got
Jordy back for round two uh Jordan I
thought a great place to start is the
debt limit crisis obviously people have
heard about it they might not know
exactly what's going on I think you're
putting a lot of weight on this you
think this is a very big moment in the
financial World explain kind of your
view as to why are you so focused on
that debt limit crisis
well first of all the it's good to be
back pumped but I
this is a good time to be back on
because the debt ceiling right now is
going to become a major news story
almost assuredly I guess there's a small
possibility that Washington decides to
not be polarized and let everything Kick
the Can down the road but it just seems
based on the track record that we're
gonna have a moment that people are
gonna get scared about this concept of
agreeing to raise the debt ceiling
because the debt continues to rise in
the country and particularly after the
rise from the pandemic where we needed
it to go up significantly uh if you
remember Joe manchin basically at the
beginning of last year really kind of
put his foot down and said I we don't
need more inflation and if we keep
spending in this Reckless manner we're
going to have more inflation well
obviously we did have more inflation we
canceled some of the spending we were
going to do and so the debt ceiling is
just taking that story and bringing it
up as kind of a story for the next
presidential election so it comes at a
time when you've got a banking crisis
and the FED during its time of doing QT
and raising rates to stop inflation had
to take a little uh exit off the Garden
State Parkway in New Jersey and do a
little bit more dumping of money uh to
deal with the banking crisis so I think
the fact that it's happening at the same
time it just comes when people are
losing trust in the banking system and I
think the debt ceiling is going to bring
some of that back to ruse in terms of
you can't spend forever well so when we
talk about that debt limit crisis and
kind of what's going on what do you
think will happen are you in the Campa
if there's going to be a U.S default do
you think it'll be avoided in like the
11th Hour what do you kind of uh at
least preparing yourself for
well again I I have to so I have this um
non-doom and Gloom belief and I probably
when I was younger I I spent more time
thinking there's no way they can keep
this debt going forever but the reality
is the debt fuels Innovation and growth
and so there's a direct relationship and
so I think they'll eventually come to
some agreement even if
there's some technical default where
they find ways to pay it off but they
have to go through some backdoor
channels the printing press is something
people have heard I don't believe
there's a printing press I believe
there's multiple printing presses and
that just means a variety of ways for
them to make sure that all debts are
paid off so my guess is it'll be the
same thing as ever there'll be a you
know a reality Congress of Washington
that'll go on uh and that'll be drama
but eventually they'll just kick the can
down the road they'll agree to raise it
there might be some spending changes but
in the end we all know that this never
lasts very long and the debt keeps
getting higher and higher as we look at
kind of that debt limit uh you're
highlighting this idea that people may
lose some faith in the U.S system they
may have some questions some uncertainty
there although you know the percentage
likelihood of a default is still low uh
it does beg the question hey what's
going on here at the same time you
mentioned the banking crisis and that to
me seems much more acute people were
very worried about their deposits we saw
massive tens of billions of dollars
outflow from certain banks in a single
day
are they related are they different how
do you look at the banking crisis in
light of kind of the debt limit stuff
uh I view them as very very similar and
I'm going to give you a a simple analogy
I've been trying to explain to people
about Banks because somehow or another
people have always just trusted that
banks are safe
um and I'm going to convert them into my
world of hedge funds so if if a hedge
fund were to go out and raise
um 200 billion dollars which is
effectively deposit size that Silicon
Valley Bank had and they took that 200
billion dollars of overnight liabilities
meaning everyone could come in and take
the money at that day if they all wanted
to and they went out and they invested
it in 10-year illiquid Securities that
were yielding higher than the overnight
rate well everyone would say well that's
definitely a a problem well the reality
is every Bank does the same thing they
take deposits in it's overnight or daily
liquidity and they invested in things
that are less liquid and so if everyone
came into a bank it's just a it's at the
end a run
is a lack of trust and so I think
there's similarity in the fact that
what's happening is through social media
through transparency people are learning
about this risk more and more so back in
2008 to 2009 during the banking crisis
if you wanted to go figure out what was
happening with Lehman Brothers you
picked up the newspaper the physical
newspaper the iPhone had just come out
most people didn't have it there was no
way to just get full transparency and
there was certainly no speed of
information it was a slow-moving thing
and that was pretty fast because you did
have the internet so you could go online
but you didn't carry the computer around
with you all the time so it didn't speed
up the information what's happening now
is through transparency through speed of
Technology people get scared very very
quickly and it's very easy to take your
money out and to move it somewhere else
so everyone has learned that with svb
and I think with the government
you have the risk of a similar thing
that people start realizing now wait a
second what actually happens during a
debt ceiling debate because the last one
that really mattered was in 2011 and
again 2011 is when
iPhone finally surpassed blackberry and
so you still didn't have the speed of
information so I think the transparency
the speed of information uh leads to
more mistrust especially with something
that if you remember the Zeitgeist thing
on what the fractional Reserve banking
system is people are learning that it is
a levered Ponzi scheme as you see the
banking crisis play out we have seen
immense amounts of support from the
deposit Insurance Fund from the treasury
the FDIC uh the uh Federal Reserve I
mean just the list goes on and on and on
all these people stepping up and saying
don't worry the financial system is safe
and sound we stand ready to provide all
the support is that stuff just all
inflationary like is that ultimately
just going to drive even more issues
that then are compounded by debt limit
uh kind of force that hand even more or
is maybe the support more of uh actual
support and isn't going to destroy kind
of the more macro environment
all right so this is where I kind of
jump off board with most people so we
had inflation and believe it or not as
of right now it appears to be transitory
much more than than maybe people thought
so you go back two years ago these feds
saying transitory uh and then it got a
little bit out of whack we printed an
enormous amount of money M2 and the
fiscal side grew at seven to nine
trillion dollars which is the same
amount of M2 growth we had seen from
2010 to 2019. we did it in effectively
two and a half years and we had Supply
bottlenecks so of course we had some
sort of inflation it got higher than
what people wanted but there were three
structural forces that remain that if
the FED weren't to find a way to print
money would eventually win out in my
belief and those are those are things
that don't change demographics people
don't get younger in fact if anything uh
believe it or not life expectancy is
shrinking so demographics and the health
side of it is getting worse not not
better you you have the debt
um assets can fall but the money you owe
on the debt does not fall just because
the assets are falling so the debt is
enormous the demographics are there and
then something that you're very familiar
with that your listeners are familiar
with exponential innovation has been
happening and going at a very fast pace
that's deflationary and with artificial
intelligence accelerating at this point
in terms of opening it up to more and
more people in usage I just don't see
how that won't overwhelm whatever the
FED could do so I think the FED is
fighting a battle always about deflation
at this point and as much as we have
transitory inflation I don't think those
three forces will let up and one of the
reasons that you went into the situation
with SBB is because those deflationary
forces absolutely positively came into
Play Because stocks went down last year
that started the whole situation the FED
had to raise rates that knocked bonds
down and now we're at a situation where
you've got a very big you know problem
in your handsome
are people actively seeking alternatives
to the us-based financial system like
are they saying to themselves not only
am I uncertain I'm nervous but I'm going
to move Capital elsewhere and so things
like gold Bitcoin Etc that are seen
outside of the system become
beneficiaries of that or is it still
just talk but not a lot of action yet
uh a I I think it's been happening
the Bitcoin paper came out at a very
important time of mistrust
um and I think the time period since
2008 uh when the paper came out just
after Lehman has really been you know 15
years or 14 years of a lot of mistrust
um whether it was the EU situation we
had to print money to keep that one
situation China's had to print money and
and raise their money supply
dramatically uh to keep their housing
market a real estate market from falling
down basically the governments of the
central banks of the the three major
economies China the U.S uh and Europe
and then if you throw in what Japan has
been doing for the last 30 years they're
trying to keep up from the debt
deflation thing taking over so I do
think gradually what's been happening
more and more users are migrating to the
crypto world and they're looking for
another alternative and rather than get
into this polarizing binary world of One
Versus the other
um you still can't function in the
crypto world meaning can't go to the
supermarket you can't do a bunch of the
things that you need so when you have a
450 trillion dollar game going on which
is the Fiat system of assets that's the
total sum of all the assets according to
Boston Consulting Group around the globe
and you have a crypto World which has
about 1 trillion
one's growing fast and the other one's
not growing and the 60 40 model is kind
of a good gauge for how Assets in the
Fiat system are doing X real estate uh
and if you go look at what 60 40 has
done since February of 20 before the
pandemic it's barely up bonds and stocks
have kind of offset each other and
Bitcoin was about ten thousand it's now
27 000 ethereum I don't remember where
the exact price is but you're dealing
with over a thousand percent in ethereum
so I think the crypto world has grown
significantly and will continue to grow
I think people want it all to happen
today but as I I said before it took
five years for the iPhone and the iOS
system to take over blackberry and I
think people want this to go faster this
is a different game and it's going to
take another 10 to 20 years but I think
the out performance will continue to
happen in the crypto world as as an
alternative along with gold for the time
being so you recently wrote a paper uh
and it's called svb chat GPT and the
future of trust the Bitcoin moment now
what's fascinating about this SBB debt
limit and bit there's a lot of people
connecting those three things you
included chat GPT from open AI why are
you looking at artificial intelligence
as a key component to this thing that
you're calling the Bitcoin moment
well the first thing is I have viewed in
my world of uh
allocators and Pension funds investing
just to give your your your viewers
slash listeners an idea the United
States right now makes up about 60 to 70
percent of the msci world stock market
meaning if you as an uh a pension fund
in Germany are benchmarked to msci world
for diversification you currently have
60 to 70 percent of your Investments
within the stock world in the United
States because our companies are bigger
than many many gdps of the world
particularly with Microsoft and Apple
um so part of the the belief in
technology with s with artificial
intelligence in the blockchain kind of
accelerating right now is I view them as
a decentralization moment now when
people hear decentralization some people
you know view this as uh it's not going
to happen it can happen well any scheme
that's going to work whether it's the
Fiat scheme or whether it's another
competitive scheme it just takes trust
and the rest of the world world is going
to benefit dramatically from the
decentralization of things like chat GPT
it allows a kid sitting in Africa to
create Amazing Ideas as long as he can
access data because he has this engine
so we used to need data scientists and
coders to do a lot of this now you just
need ideas you're taking the art of
coding and you're making it something
that's commoditized which allows other
countries to come up with ideas to solve
problems and I think they're sitting
there with brains that didn't go through
the same school system which in my
opinion
you know forces people to have a rigid
thing like a major where ideas are
really kind of global and so I have
viewed this moment for the Bitcoin
moment as a as a moment for artificial
intelligence and blockchain to start the
real passion for decentralization
through the U.S no longer having the
dominant place for technology and
Innovation and that it's going to spread
and when people hear this they think
well you're negative on the U.S
innovation no we'll still be a global
leader in Innovation I just think the
rest of the world is going to grow at a
faster Pace in this because they
depended on our technology and now
they're going to have stuff which is
going to allow them to speed up the
competitiveness you ended this letter
with the following passage you said
trust in the stories of the pillars of
the Fiat system is breaking down each
day the belief in the government's
ability to keep the leaning tower of
Leverage from falling is driving talent
and capital to A New Path in the
cryptocurrency world I think artificial
intelligence and the deposit flight in
the banking system are both moments that
will accelerate this distrust and be a
significant inflection point for the
Bitcoin story told in the decades to
come when I read that what I took away
was one these are Trends this is not a
static photo in a moment in time so the
banking deposits is not just about what
happened on Thursday and Friday before
SBB collapsed it is part of this trend
of loss of trust in the banking system
the debt limit crisis is not just about
this specific debt limit crisis but the
overarching trend of loss of the U.S
government's ability to control debt and
various other things that they're doing
but also Bitcoin is a moving Target as
well there's a story there's not a
static evaluation of it how do you look
at Bitcoins kind of rise over the last
couple of years right obviously
pre-pandemic I think Bitcoin was
drastically seen as kind of a toy by
many people there weren't a lot of kind
of macro uh kind of Wall Street hedge
fund managers that were talking about it
openly to the public that all changed in
2020 going into 2021. how do you
evaluate that time period now
yeah it's it's it's really interesting
because when you go through it the whole
point of writing the paper was that
there's a lot that's happened since 2020
and we get caught up in
the growth rate of things so you know we
had M2 grow by an enormous amount in a
short amount of time I tweeted today
that last month or I'm sorry in March it
was the largest percentage decline in M2
in the country going back to the 1950s
we had an over one percent drop in M2
now 85 percent of M2 is Bank deposits so
to your point we have Bank deposits that
are declining but if you go back and
look at svb the story that people hear
is SBB collapsed and they lost 200
billion of deposits part of the story
was they only had less than 50 billion
in February of 2020.
they gained 150 billion dollars of
deposits during the pandemic and they
had to turn around and invest that money
somewhere else so when you really read
the story people get focused on the
collapse I get focused on how could a
bank attract 150 billion of deposits
during a pandemic when people can't
leave their home and this was obviously
the printing of the fed the helicopter
money the Ben Bernanke had had put out
and so when you look at it and you go
through and like okay so the deposits
went up dramatically now they're
declining but the decline has never
happened before and that's the thing
people have to realize is that I look
for things that are new the decline in
deposits is a new thing the regional
banks are falling and people see them in
the news and you have a lot of smart
people saying it's not going to stop
that cannot be minimized as an event it
cannot be minimized as something that's
important those Regional Banks they're
part of the decentralization movement
because who are the banks that benefit
it's Wells Fargo it's JP Morgan it's
Bank of America it's all the big five
and the the too big to fail Banks and so
that has led to people looking for
another alternative and if you want to
use an analogy I use the Blackberry iOS
think about your grandparents and the
people that were maybe in their 70s and
80s who refused to get an iPhone
who didn't use Uber they were looking
for taxis and what eventually got them
to force was to change were two things
and I have my my stepfather is 89 as of
last week and he did not use an Uber I
think until 2019 just before the
pandemic and if I asked him why
he eventually reached a point he's like
well this thing has lasted for 10 years
so I guess I got to do it at some point
he got an iPhone in 2018 it took those
events but then there was one other
thing it was the fact that it was
cheaper it was easier and I think that's
what's going to happen with with uh
Bitcoin is more and more people are
going to see that it's easier that it's
becoming an OG by being around now for
15 years so it isn't going away and when
they start highlighting or they start
paying attention which is why I included
the numbers if you include crypto
Bitcoin as an asset in your portfolio
you've done exceptionally well over the
last 10 years but even over the last
three years you've done exceptionally
well only last year would you have done
poorly and again Amazon was down close
to 50 last year so it's not like this
was isolated to this this was Innovation
when you look at the past performance
can it continue one and two is how do
you start to try to measure what your
expectations there would be right we
have a programmatic monetary uh policy
so we kind of know what Bitcoin is going
to come into circulation demand is the
big variable and so how do you start to
try to wrap your head around that as an
asset allocator
all right so I'm going to give you the
formula that I've shown in my my videos
that I do kind of once every two weeks
with charts just to highlight what I
view as a macro person
um Bitcoin is and there's a lot of
people that I would say are completely
in the web 3 blockchain crypto world
that I speak with that don't View
it that way but I think they're starting
to come to the conclusion that the
funding for any growth in the crypto
world comes from the Fiat world so you
have to follow charts in the Fiat world
that represent the growth of Bitcoin so
to me the first one is when Innovation
is doing well so right now if you wanted
to pick a chart for that when the ndx
which is the Innovation index is
outperforming the SPX which is dominated
by the older industrial parts of the
economy when that's outperforming
Bitcoin is generally doing well the
second thing is the focus that I said
with two things on the United States if
you believe that the U.S that the rest
of the world is catching up and they
don't have as much faith in the U.S then
you've got number one the fed and how
that's being viewed well the banking
sector and kind of needing to print
they're watching that they're going to
watch the debt ceiling so I think
people's confidence in the U.S will
continue to decline around the globe
particularly in Asia the next thing is
the dollar when the dollar is weakening
typically Bitcoin is done by well I
don't think people realize this but the
two big major rallies in in Bitcoin
since 2015 occurred in 2017 and 2020.
we're going we started another one
appears in November of 22. those all
were times that the dollar was weakening
now November of 22 also happens to be
the time that chat GPT was released and
I think that has an impact too as I
mentioned but you're you're at a point
now where I think Bitcoin is gathering
because people are losing trust in the
US and then finally this goes without
people realizing but I talk about this
all the time this year in 2023 70 of
global growth will occur in Asia China
and India will will be the bulk of it
but you're dealing with other countries
in Asia that continue to grow at a rapid
pace and China in particular's M2 has
grown by five trillion dollars since
October so we talked about the U.S
growth China is the single biggest money
supply country on the on in the plant on
the planet almost double the us at this
point so when China's money supply is
increasing which was not happening last
year Bitcoin typically does well and
right now all of those things are
pointed the same direction you have the
AI Innovation side you have the FED
under attack along with the dollar
because of the banking sector and the
debt ceiling and you have Asia
dominating the growth because the
China's reopening and the printing of
money
as we see all that growth in China and
other places we saw Pakistan go ahead
and ban ownership of Bitcoin we saw
China come out very very strongly and
kick out all the miners we saw Nigeria
uh ban uh the trading of cryptocurrency
we've seen India talk about doing it
these are countries some of them are
very fast growing some of them are
already very large population wise some
of them are very high penetration of
mobile is it a thing where the
government and the people are separate
or should we actually put value and
Credence on the fact that some of these
governments seem to be taking abrasive
steps towards something like Bitcoin
uh so I've I've first of all if you go
back and look at all the times that
China's done something that would be
negative for Bitcoin it still goes up
and everyone who has kids I'll always
say the same thing the one way to ensure
your kid does something is to tell them
they can't do it so every time that a
regulation comes that you can't own
Bitcoin or you can't do this people will
find a way to do it because that must
mean it's something that is absolutely a
viable alternative to the government
because why would they be seeing
otherwise so when you get into the
global growth story and this is my
favorite kind of comparison uh
there's Global growth this year in Asia
Global growth this year for uh the world
will be 70 Asia
the crypto users of the world almost 70
percent are in Asia and this again gets
back into the point that there's a
global belief by a lot of people that
attend events for allocators and for
hedge funds and all this stuff that the
U.S dominates technology because that's
what happened in 2000 really from 1994
with Netscape all the way up to even
without China last year I believe the
crypto thing is a growing Universe of
people outside the U.S axi Infinity was
an example of it the fact that Africa
has 38 million users in the U.S has 45
million users you cannot ignore the fact
that the growth and the dominance is the
rest of the world in crypto and so they
may not have as much money and China is
a big money player the US is a big money
player the rest of the world they don't
have that much money so it takes a while
for it to grow but I think the new phase
is that Innovation will be driving it
and I absolutely believe that immutable
data has never been more important
because of what happened with svb
because of AI picking up and I think
that's where the intersection of the
blockchain and AI run together the more
that you have something like chat gbt
which can create fake stuff overnight
can create could create hallucinations
immutable data becomes even more
important because you have something
that can create so much fake data very
very quickly and so they almost work
together and that's why I think for Asia
and for even the governments they're
going to be forced to move to the
blockchain and I believe any investments
in the blockchain indirectly impact
Bitcoin because the money stays inside
the system so I think there'll be a lot
more investment in the blockchain you
and I spoke briefly for a minute
beforehand but just this morning the
fact that Goldman Sachs and Microsoft
joined on a new you know on on forces on
a blockchain network I think people have
to start watching that Microsoft keeps
being brought up in everything and with
their investment in open AI it just kind
of feels like people should be watching
more wherever their name is stuck in
because I think it's going to keep
popping up in in places like this with
the blockchain how much does like the
Federal Reserve or other types of what
I'll call traditional macro data points
matter in a world of innovation and
technology so as we saw obviously the
top of kind of the last bull market both
in Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies but also
in the tech sector uh and in the stock
market was kind of Q4 2021 obviously the
fed's stepping in saying hey we're going
to tighten things kind of put a damper
on the party going forward when you get
this kind of explosive uh growth when
you get true Innovation does the FED
kind of impact get muted to some degree
are they able to manipulate interest
rates or conduct quantitative easing
that can really have as big of an impact
as maybe an environment where there
wasn't so much Innovation happening and
how much do you kind of pay attention to
okay we got technology on one side and
kind of all the Innovation and exciting
shiny stuff and we almost got kind of
like the boring blocking and tackling of
like what's the FED gonna do and what's
Global liquidity going to do in order to
make decisions overlap or no
yeah so I'll I'll just kind of give my
views on what last year was more than
anything and I think you you should use
svb as kind of the
the poster child of what happened with
Innovation because why did they take in
150 billion dollars from 40 it's not
like every Bank grew as fast as they did
in deposits those deposits were coming
into the Technology Innovation space
which had received enormous amounts of
money because of the printing that went
on so when you all of a sudden add a
bunch of printing into the system of
trillions of dollars at a time when
everyone's sitting at home and the old
economy is not being used in any way the
old economy has debt well of course the
only place that benefited was technology
and software and seeing at home in
crypto and all the things while we were
all locked in for a pandemic then the
second that we were allowed to come out
and the second that the supply chains
were allowed to kind of normalize we had
the lag effect of inflation because we
were spending from our home so I don't
think last year in terms of the move and
Innovation was a negative thing I think
it was more repricing if you go look at
where the MDX is and you you'll look at
where all this stuff is they've
basically equated to like a 13 to 15
percent annualized gain since before the
pandemic meaning the NASDAQ is up since
the pan since February of 2020 but it
went up way too much for a pandemic then
it corrected and now it's starting to go
up again so last year was not about
rates going higher in my opinion it was
not about inflation going higher it was
the fact that the Fed was so far behind
the curve that they had to play quick
catch up and for those of you who don't
follow kind of what's happened in June
uh June 14th of last year the FED funds
rate was one percent
currently it's five to five and a
quarter the 10-year rate
back in June 14th was three and a half
percent it's currently three and a half
percent so short-term rates went higher
but long-term rates did not go higher
and you hear a lot of things in the
Press about the inversion of the yield
curve but the reality is for me the
market is now building in the power of
innovation and the deflationary forces
that come with it I just left the
conversation with one of our commodity
Traders and you've read a lot about
running out of oil that was all of last
year's theme yet Boyle's gone since
Russia invaded Ukraine from a peak up
near 130 140 and it's been sitting
around 70 dollars and the question is if
you believe that chat gbt is really
going to be able to us for us to solve
complex problems what's the probability
that in five years we haven't come up
with some solution uh on either the
efficiency of extracting oil the
efficient the efficiency of using oil or
something that comes in as an
alternative I would say the power of
compounding ideas is growing rapidly and
so you should have oil that five years
from now is not as big a problem and I
think that's what's happened is
innovation starting to reassert itself
right now how are you starting to use
some of these Technologies internally
right you guys run a business you're an
entire investing practice obviously
something like chat GPT has all these
promises that come along with it there's
artificial intelligence I know that you
are even going back and learning even
more about coding and kind of software
development Etc like explain what you
guys are thinking could be ways for you
to use it internally not just as an
asset allocation
yeah I I mean artificial intelligence
and what's happening with the with chat
GPT has just allowed us to do already so
many things focused on efficiency so I I
do these
um these these videos every two weeks as
I said there's about 30 charts I go
through with pictures I did one today so
charts of what's happening in the
economy why it doesn't look like there's
any systemic risk despite what you're
reading in the paper so I actually I use
actual data to do this now to do it I do
it myself and the reason I was like you
know what I gotta start coding again so
I got to go back to my python class and
get reading because there's now things
that you can connect GPT to to allow you
to just come up with the idea and let it
do the chart and that's what I want to
do is why should I keep going through
trying to create these charts by seeing
a pattern and then matching it up when I
can just let artificial intelligence
find a pattern that matches up and I'll
just direct them in that manner so we're
doing it on that front we're also doing
it on optimization and portfolio
construction we're also doing it on
trying to find
things that maybe people should change
up like have they become too correlated
to a given Factor that's out there or
something that's moved help their
decision making I think the biggest
thing it's going to do is really impact
human
human decision making so I spent a lot
of time on behavioral decision making I
think a lot of the losses that happen in
a period where things are less
predictable which is I think what's
happening we're just things are changing
so quickly that your decision making
takes away a lot of Alpha from your
ability and so a lot of the stuff we're
focused on is on efficiency it's not
thinking we have the Holy Grail of of
back testing something or going through
it uh everything in markets is about
behavioral decision making because it's
a power Mutual system one thing goes up
another thing goes down the odds change
every day I still believe humans have an
advantage but I think their weakness is
their decision making and so we're
spending a lot of time on how to
optimize their decision making or to
highlight the things that they're doing
wrong to see if they can make some
changes
do you think artificial intelligence can
eventually do your job or do you think
that it's something where it will uh it
may take time it can augment but you're
still going to need kind of a human to
hit the button you're still going to
need a human to make the final call like
how far can this go and and I don't
think it's probably next year we're
talking you know maybe we're talking 10
20 years from now like could it really
replace investors and asset allocators
or is it harder to see that right now
I I I I I think I learned a while ago
that anything past five years the
probability of having any idea of what's
going to happen goes down so
dramatically that I try to stay
especially when technology is changing
so quickly I try to stay with inside the
the one to two year maybe three-year
area but with things like energy or
let's say longevity you know solving
things those are math problems to me and
it's just a function of getting there
the job because of I mean let's put it
this way autonomous vehicles should
already be on the road and the only
thing stopping them from being on the
road is not the technology it's humans
um and it's I I think humans will slow
down the process but do I think that the
job of everyone in any industry
will either be replaced or you'll be
working more in line with computers I've
always had a belief that human plus
machine has been impacting the workforce
for a long time artificial intelligence
is another technology we all know the
positives that come with it but we also
are scared to death that the negatives
come that come with it and so the
regulations will slow it down everything
there's going to be major issues that
pop out of it I'm sure and I think human
beings will still have that trust factor
that people want because I've referenced
the book sapiens in there and sapiens is
about
us and we need stories and as someone
who goes out if you try to go to an
investor and say hey I have this
artificial intelligence here are the
numbers it put out the last 10 years and
this is what it's done so far this year
give me money
people are going to say well what does
it do say I don't know it's artificial
intelligence it's just working
people don't like that story and so
humans need to be involved if for no
other reason for the comfort of the
stories and hearing them and that's
going to take a long time to get through
so the same way we don't trust the
government and we don't trust the banks
we don't trust computers either and so I
think as much as artificial intelligence
will
be important for a world I don't think
it can replace humans until time has
gone by and people really can't
differentiate between computers and
humans and I think that's a long way off
yeah you said earlier that humans are
going to slow it down what do you mean
by that
we we value certain things that um
that computers don't
so autonomous vehicles if you go through
it if one person dies in an autonomous
vehicle it's a major story
uh and it doesn't matter if in the same
night that one person died that there
were seven seven other deaths within the
same city that happened for drunk
driving or something along those lines
we don't equate them the same way uh and
that's just gonna take time and I think
people are gonna have inertia out of
fear uh out of fear of death but also
out of fear of losing their jobs and at
the end of the day we both know that
people vote based on their fears and
they vote based on what they want and so
if you want to protect your job you want
to vote for people who don't agree with
allowing AI to be brought too fast and
that's why other countries that don't
have that voting side or in China's case
aren't trying to keep control I believe
the two countries that will
have the hardest time
or create the biggest regulations will
be China and the U.S because they have
the most to lose and I think the
countries that will benefit the most I
lived in Brazil for two years uh their
problem was about education it was about
the government and Corruption a whole
bunch of different items that I think
artificial intelligence and transparency
can help with and because people there
have had such a bad side at some point
Their Fear is not participating and
they're getting the freedom they can
that I think is there I've said I really
do believe the crypto world to some
people on the planet is like what the
what America was to people when they
came over here a land of Freedom a land
of less centralization less control and
I think that's going to be where many of
the great ideas are coming out of so I
think China and the U.S uh will have the
people that slow down the process
through regulation and through fear more
than the other countries one of the best
ways that I know to kind of think about
you know where the future is going is to
look at young people and so let's say
that a 10 year old or a 15 year old came
to you and said hey I'm really excited
about uh the world like what should I do
uh whether they wanted to be an investor
or maybe they wanted to build a company
or whatever what would you say for them
to go study is it just learn software
development and pay attention to Ai and
Bitcoin or is there maybe some more
nuanced things that you would give in
terms of advice of what young people
could go do to be prepared for the
future
I have a 17 year old son who wants to go
to school for computer science and uh
luckily the schools he's choosing all
happen to be in Boston and they're very
difficult to get into they're almost
impossible to get into if you go in as a
computer science major and what I've
been trying to explain to him recently
is that I think the Arts are going to be
far more important I've believed that if
you think about what chat GPT can do
with writing I write a lot I do a lot of
content I do we have we have a podcast
I'm on that I'm always trying to find
ways to bring new ideas and kind of
fresh ideas out well writing has become
so much easier so when you type chat GPT
and writing most of what you get is
about the plagiarism side and it doing
it and how schools are going to fight it
off that's the negative side for me it
makes it more efficient if I come up
with a two-paragraph idea and I ask chat
CPT to edit it and expand it now I'm
getting a lot more connections dot
Connections in there and then I can read
that and I can expand it more but the
idea was still mine so what I've talked
to my son about is to make sure that the
Arts are a major part and I'd rather
have an art degree or something in the
Arts psychology whatever combined with a
computer science degree and that would
give them the ability of that
storytelling that I think and that's the
thing that I do believe at the end of
the day humans need they need
storytelling they need the ability to
communicate with each other and kids
more than anything have access to data
in a very quick way but none of my kids
call me up saying hey is this SBB thing
a big deal but my parents did my friends
did everyone else was wondering what it
was and that's why for kids I think they
already have the computer skills I want
them to get more involved with the Arts
and so that's the way I've kind of
approached it
what type of books are you spending your
time reading right now given how fast
the world is moving and what makes me
think about this is
um I think a lot of people previously
thought robotics was going to be
disruptive to manufacturing Etc
um but I also think that uh there are a
ton of folks who
um now are saying wait if artificial
intelligence is going to be powerful if
Bitcoin is going to take decision making
out of the hands of uh throw reserve and
central banks it changes maybe the type
of information that becomes interesting
or the things that you read has there
been any change or what are the books
you're spending your time reading
I've I've had this thing that I've said
on my podcast for years which are um I
now has never been more true books are a
waste of time
um there's knowledge in them that is
incredibly useful but to get through uh
sapiens which is 500 pages would never
happen if you haven't done this and many
of your your viewers listeners are
probably used or have blinkist
I don't know how blinkist can survive
anymore because
you can say to chat GPT Give me a
summary of sapiens give me the chapters
in Sapien give me the D it will do it
for you uh and if people haven't done
that that is the easiest way to consume
knowledge so what has happened for me
over the years I have themes that I care
about longevity is a big one for me
because a I believe in it and secondly I
want the most Cutting Edge research for
my own health on what I should be doing
so I spend a lot of time reading on
futuristic things that will have an
impact on me like that now I'm doing a
lot on coding and certain GPT plug-ins
that I can use in my world so different
things like openbb is something I'm
spending time on which allows you to
kind of do some of the things I do with
charts I always have a different area I
spent probably 200 hours over a very
short amount of time which meant about
14 hours a day over the course of two
weeks during times where I was home for
the pandemic on web 3.0 I didn't know
enough about it but you can learn an
enormous amount without going into a
book and I've always called it I like
rabbit hole learning it's why I didn't
like school I'll make a connection to
another topic and then I'll go read
about it so as I'm sitting here and I'm
reciting a bunch of data to you on
everything ranging from the size of the
Fiat Ponzi scheme to how much uh China's
money supply has gone those numbers come
from me kind of ping-ponging around to
data that I think is having an impact
and that's the way that I learn and so
I've given up on books a while ago but I
do kind of use chat GPT and I did use
blinkist to get the summaries I was
always a cliff notes person when I was a
kid so I was the exact same way I've
gone the opposite though now I start
reading a lot more uh kind of more in
depth but there's not a lot of uh um
kind of nuanced new information many of
the books I read are a little bit older
and so you really got to kind of be
careful that you don't get sucked into
just that alone uh Jordan to give you an
idea I've watched probably 13 YouTubes
today like that's what that's the way I
consume information now and they range
from coding to to how to use a voodoo
floss band from my knee whole bunch of
things but that's the way I consume a
lot of information on One X or 2x speed
at this so with YouTube it's all 1X on
all any books and stuff everything is 2x
so if I do get a book
um that I really want to consume I'm the
same way I'm like all right I just don't
want it to be more than three hours so
I'll do it on 2x yeah that is uh that's
incredible um when you start thinking
about asset allocation what have you
guys been changing over the last you
know call it six months or so are there
certain things that you're technically
set up for outside of what we've been
talking about or things that you're
intentionally avoiding
um because uh you think that maybe
something bad's coming there
we so things change rapidly I'll just
say right now with where things are
um we do
so I I don't think there's going to be a
recession that matters meaning so a
recession That Matters to everyone since
they're probably like wait I just read
that it's definitely going to be a
recession
my definition of a recession for
everyone out there is where we lose at
least one and a half percent of the
workforce uh that means we'd have to
lose about 2.5 million jobs because
there's about 150 million people working
uh I don't think that's going to happen
and the reason is because we have a
labor shortage if we do have it it may
happen over time uh and you will see
artificial intelligence take away some
jobs over the course of the next five
years but in the short term any new
innovation usually leads to more so
because I don't think there's a
recession but I also think inflation has
peaked and is coming down in the banking
crisis is acting as a credit contraction
thing we may see a technical recession
where we actually have a negative GDP
number or negative couple of negative
GDP but not a systemic recession which
means something like the great financial
crisis or the pandemic uh but something
that's more moderate and if that's the
case people should be focused on
Innovation if you want to go look at you
know a
um how the NASDAQ is trading and how
Microsoft is helping the NASDAQ you
really have to remember in 2009 we had
an innovation boom because the iPhone
had come out during the great financial
crisis and then coming out of it Apple
LED this massive rise so we really focus
on Believe It or Not technology holding
in there very well I also don't think
since there's going to be a recession
that you're going to have any negative
Type move on uh the old economy stuff so
Commodities will be fine but the real
thing that we're focused on is that the
stock markets in the rest of the world
will outperform the US for a lot of the
reasons that I said and then the final
thing is uh unless something changes
quickly on the banking crisis and the
debt ceiling I would expect that the
dollar is in a kind of permanent
weakening Trend it won't collapse but I
do think more and more money will be
draining out of it and again that's one
of the reasons why I'm positive actually
all those reasons why I'm positive on
bitcoin at this moment
when you look at Bitcoin specifically
um what is the strategy in terms of uh
kind of allocating to it are you guys
trying to trade it are you trying to buy
and hold it forever is it we're buying
it we have some kind of you know price
Target like how do you think about this
asset which you know you're very bullish
on it seems to have this like
exponential growth to it that seems very
different than maybe a traditional stock
or something like that
um there's some risks when it comes to
regulation or various other things that
people are talking about
how do you wrap your head around like
what is the strategy once you said okay
I need Bitcoin is that as a Trader or a
holder or what
so we managed about four billion dollars
and our mandate is not to have anything
in the crypto world so we don't now what
I'll say is number one that's what makes
it good about me writing about and going
through it is I'm not some Zealot who's
you know got his entire life uh job
involved in the crypto world I'm
actually in the Fiat World 100 with our
investors I have my own personal
Investments uh in the crypto world that
I believe in but the way I translate it
back into the Fiat world is what I said
I believe Innovation and micro if you
want to be long Bitcoin at this point I
think you want to be long AI I think you
want to be long Innovation which means
the NASDAQ or the ndx will outperform
the s p uh if you believe that Bitcoin
is going higher then the fed and the
dollar will be places that you just are
taking the opposite side of and
believing that the FED is going to have
to print money to keep this bubble from
bursting and that means that although we
won't have high end we're definitely
going to have more money printing going
on because it's going to become
necessary as people lose trust and
that's one thing we didn't get into math
and that's what people should realize
the US has about as you're learning 18
trillion dollars of deposits that is the
bottom part of the Ponzi scheme so that
funds the fact that the household net
worth in the country on top of 18
trillion dollars is 150 trillion well
that's the fractional Reserve banking
system which the banks provide leverage
to allow that assets to go up that much
the deposits are leaving as the deposits
leave they're going into the money
market funds money market funds don't
give you the leverage can't you can't
get leverage from it it's just sitting
in something kind of like theoretically
Bitcoin so if you move it in there yes
you're getting a yield you're getting
paid on it but they can't go lend that
money out so you have this money that no
longer is part of the fractional Reserve
banking so the more that that goes on
leaving deposits M2 goes down it puts
pressure on the the levered Ponzi scheme
and so the only way for do is the Fed is
to add the money back in to keep the
assets from falling because if the
household net worth went from 150
trillion to 100 trillion we'd have a
serious systemic recession so I believe
that the dollar and the FED needing to
print money is another way that we're
long Bitcoin here believing that those
two things are going to go on and then
finally if you believe in the Asia
growth story in the Emerging Markets
benefiting from the decentralization of
technology away from the us having a
monopoly that's another way to belong
Bitcoin so that's the way that we kind
of deal with it uh without having to be
a zealot on crypto so where can we send
people to find you on the internet or
find out more what you guys are doing
all of the content that I do is on is on
G Weiss g w e i s s.com uh including the
videos that I do every week but you can
get access to the papers and everything
there and then for those people who like
podcasts um in search of green marbles
is our podcast and it goes on once a
week it's about 20 20 to 25 minutes it's
covering the markets and all the big
macro Global themes the FED China things
along those lines and then I can be uh
people can follow me on on Twitter I
think it's at
this sir underscore Weiss something like
that I don't know they can find me in
there somewhere
but I always appreciate I appreciate
talking with you because you come out of
the kind of traditional Financial world
and you have a great understanding and
Mastery of how to allocate capital in
that world but you're one of the most
open-minded people I know in terms of uh
being able to look at all this new
technology and rather than run from it
you actually run to it and you say hey
what is this and you kind of turn it
over and look at it you're trying to
really figure it out
um and uh the data point to me that just
speaks volumes in terms of how you
approach this stuff is you're literally
going back to Learn Python more so that
you can then go and use the technology
and I just wish that more people in the
world had that kind of attitude of look
let me go get my hands dirty let me
actually use this stuff and then I'll
form my opinion right and once you kind
of get to that uh that opinion
um it's got a little bit more substance
behind it than just hey I read a
headline and now I feel like you know
I'm with the uh the next great uh
pontificator when it comes to a certain
new technology or New Market opportunity
yeah I I appreciate that and for those
of you who I mean I'm 56. anyone who's
picked up chat GPT and tried to play
with it when I first asked it a question
it basically told me I was an idiot and
literally I was like what time does The
Net game start today
and it gave me the wrong answer and I
think it did it intentionally and I
remember looking and I was like you know
what that's a search engine thing why am
I doing this in here and I started
playing more with it and then I started
talking to a lot of people on how to get
the most out of it and they were the
ones that said you're gonna have to code
in Python but you don't have to be like
proficient the whole point of it is that
if you can do enough in it to get it to
go you're going to be able to do an
amazing amount of things with it with
some of these plugins so that just said
to me for the first time before if I
wanted to go back and Learn Python to be
adapt to really work with my data
scientist it never seemed like a good
use of time I wouldn't be using it
enough because I'm too busy with
the GPT plugins I absolutely will have
it and that's where it's going to be and
because I do so much work that I can be
more efficient on I think that's the key
to any technology it's why I cook it's
why I do anything if you think you can
do something to make your life more
efficient to make it cheaper I don't
like going out to dinner as much as I
used to because I've become a really
really good cook and it wouldn't have
been without technology because most of
the ways that I learned how to cook
happen through watching it on technology
and YouTube and watching the way
ingredients and everything went through
a recipe is just words but actually
watching someone do it gives you the
pattern recognition it gives you the
memory but it also sees how it goes and
that's why things like the Food Network
were so popular the thing about YouTube
is the more that my son told me he
didn't need my help on things because he
was just going to look it up on YouTube
that was the point that I realized oh my
gosh I really have to make sure that I'm
not leaving the way to learn in
technology because technology has opened
up the ability to learn much much faster
and I think if you learn much faster
your brain stays sharper you stay
younger and I think it makes you less
intimidated and honestly it makes you
less rigid so that's the reason why I do
it and I appreciate it back to you uh
you commend me on it so lifelong learner
those are always welcome here Jordy
thank you so much for your time we'll
definitely do this again in the future
appreciate it pop thanks so much